I hear that you want to stop and I hear
that you know you talked about how
trauma actually LED you there so my
thing is what are the practical steps
that you are taking right now to stop or
is is it just like a resolution in your
mind no I'm building businesses I've got
a proper property portfolio I've got
five properties under my belt I'm about
to have another five next year I want to
make my property portfolio so big that
in two years time I won't have to do it
anymore I can pay someone to get as much
of it off the internet as possible yes I
know it probably won't all come off the
internet I'm just gonna try my best
you have five businesses though five
businesses
it's not enough financially no